there's something I found out this week
I didn't realize this the Lincoln
Memorial turned 100 1922. I thought oh
yeah okay
we can all agree on the Lincoln Memorial
we love the Lincoln Memorial and it is
sort of a perfect metaphor for America
right now a republican who experienced
gun violence and did nothing
uh
just
well people are a little angry about
what happened there that the police in
the horrible shooting in Texas a couple
of weeks ago when they just remained
outside but you know the police in Texas
are very conservative they said we don't
go in unless it's an active groomer
situation foreign
[Applause]
Texas police they are very pro-life
mostly their own
so Biden did you see that President
Biden made a big speech last night about
gun control
oh good we also
yeah
I meant to watch but the other 300
channels were showing a movie where some
guy looked cool shooting people
uh
but once again Biden said we got to get
rid of the semi-automatic rifles I say
we should yes I think that would help a
little and he said if you get
he said from now on if you get caught
with the wrong kind of gun killing
people you are in big trouble
in a somewhat related story did you see
a nut in Italy or Paris attacked the
Mona Lisa with cake
cake and the honor the NRA put out a
statement they said
only the other paintings had cake of
Their Own